durante cientos de años los matemáticos
han estado fascinados por las sumas
infinitas que llamamos series uno más un
medio más un tercio más un cuarto y
seguimos sumando así por siempre esto es
interesante en varios aspectos y es algo
que se presta para analizar con más
detalle uno entre uno más uno entre dos
más uno entre tres cada uno de estos
términos se vuelve más y más pequeño se
aproximan a cero pero cuando sumamos
todos estos términos infinitos juntos
obtenemos un número finito o diverge y
no llega a un número finito esto también
aparece en la música y quizá ese haya
sido uno de los primeros motivos para
estudiar estas series en donde tenemos
una nota o frecuencia fundamental
musical aunque el objetivo de este vídeo
no es enseñar música pero sí tenemos una
nota fundamental que puede ser un do
puro o algo así aquí les muestro solo
una de sus longitudes de onda que
continúa así las armónicas son las
frecuencias que a nuestros oídos parece
que refuerza en esa nota
y lo que ocurre con las armónicas es que
tienen la mitad de la longitud de onda
de la nota principal en este caso 2 y
que lucen más o menos así esta es una
armónica de do y tiene la mitad de la
longitud de onda noten que cuando
termina su segunda forma de onda termina
en el mismo punto que la nota principal
y hay otra armónica que tiene una
tercera parte de la longitud de onda de
do y otra armónica con la cuarta parte
de la longitud de onda de do y si vemos
varios instrumentos musicales algo que
nos parece que se escucha bien resulta
que no sólo tocan la nota fundamental
sino también incluyen muchas armónicas
pero de cualquier forma este fue un
ejemplo bastante largo para justificar
porque a esto se le llama serie armónica
en un siguiente vídeo demostraremos que
aunque no quiero estropear la sorpresa
esto realmente diverge y encontraremos
reglas generales para saber si cosas que
lucen así convergen o divergen la serie
armónica en particular divergen
que si escribimos esto en notación sigma
lo haríamos así desde n igual a uno
hasta infinito de 1 entre m otra cosa
interesante es qué pasaría si pusiéramos
algunos exponentes aquí ya comentamos
que esto que escribo por acá es la serie
armónica 1 entre 1 que es uno más uno
entre dos más uno entre tres y así
sucesivamente pero qué sucedería si
elevamos cada uno de estos denominadores
a la segunda potencia tendríamos algo
que luce así la suma desde que n es
igual a 1 hasta infinito de 1 entre n a
la segunda potencia ahora tendríamos 1
entre 1 a la segunda potencia que es 1 y
que podemos escribir todo como 1 más 1 /
2 al cuadrado que es un cuarto más 1
entre 3 al cuadrado que es un noveno y
seguimos así hasta el infinito y podemos
generalizar esto digamos que queremos
una clase general de series que
describimos como sigue desde n igual a 1
hasta infinito
de 1 / n elevado a la potencia p donde
puede ser cualquier exponente esto
quedaría como 1 más 1 / 2 a la p + 1
entre 3 a la p + 1 entre 4 a la p
etcétera y p no tiene que ser un valor
entero que podría ser un medio en cuyo
caso tendríamos 1 más 1 entre la raíz
cuadrada de 2 más 1 entre la raíz
cuadrada de 3 etcétera toda esta clase
de series de la cual la serie armónica
es un caso especial en el que p es igual
a 1 se conoce como serie es pep y no es
difícil de recordar que la p viene de la
potencia a la que se elevan los
denominadores aunque también podríamos
verlo como que se eleva toda la
expresión ya que 1 elevado a cualquier
exponente siempre será igual a 1 pero ya
les di a entender que quizá algunas de
estas convergen y otras divergen y vamos
a demostrarlo en próximos vídeos pero el
principio general es que si p es mayor a
1 entonces la serie converge lo que
tiene sentido porque significa que los
términos van a disminuir suficientemente
rápido porque mientras más grande sea el
exponente de ese denominador quiere
decir que ese denominador crecerá más
rápidamente por lo que la fracción se
hará más pequeña más rápido y si p es
menor o igual a 1 y cuando p es igual a
1 tenemos la famosa serie armónica
tenemos una situación en la que la serie
divergen y demostraremos esto en futuros
vídeos